all right we'll make starts thanks for
coming along the late Friday afternoon
good you've all stuck around excellent
we're going to talk about lowering which
is a word that if you say it enough at
me loses all its meaning but there's a
pretty good chance that some of you
won't know what it means anyway so let's
talk about it what is lowering so
imagine you're writing a compiler
c-sharp Ambala and your job is to write
a method that takes a for each loop the
code for one and outputs some al
composite this is not how a compiler is
written let's pretend that we have one
method called compile forage now IL is
I'm gonna say reasonably complicated
because I don't understand it and
therefore it's magic but c-sharp I do
understand
so in my mind I'm thinking well rather
than write this for each - IL method I
know how to rewrite a for each loop as a
for loop so I will write that and now I
can worry about writing a full loop - IL
method i kill two birds with one stone
great do less work and of course then
you keep thinking like well a for loop
is just a while loop if you reorder bits
and if you really want to go crazy a
while loop well you could just write
that using go-to statements and now if I
convert all this c-sharp and stay in a
language that I like and understand I
can write one method to compile that -
IL and I get sort of four things for the
price of one right if we do go all the
way to IL with this little code snippet
and this is the only il in the talk and
I barely understand it so don't worry
but this is what essentially all of
those bits of code look like kind of and
you know there's familiar things here we
have get items so we're pulling an item
out of the loop we have get count we
have to do that to compare the count at
the end and at the end here we have the
bacon lettuce and tomato sandwich which
is not what that means but I told you I
didn't know al that actually means
branch if less then that is the thing at
the end that says we've got a count from
our loop we've got a you know value in
our index er if there's still more to go
let's loop back around it does a branch
and if you have any experience with il
or with assembly because they're very
similar branching is kind of all that
can do right there is no blocks in il
you can't have like it doesn't have loop
constructs it's all just branching which
kind of means it's all just go twos so
if you think about having to implement a
for each loop if you've got a writer if
you've got to implement in an il and you
therefore will have to use go twos maybe
it is easier to go all the way through
to goto statements in c-sharp before you
get there that's not actually what
happens but anyway so lower ring is
going through these lower level
constructs but in the language that like
in the same language in the language
that you're compiling
so there you go Eric Lippert
has that little sentence I don't
actually know if Lauren is a is a sort
of technically correct term but it seems
to be what everyone calls it so that's
what I called it but basically the idea
is you stay in the same language you
just go through lower level features if
you go from a high level language to a
low level language well that's called
compiling so doesn't make sense to call
it that the thing is we all well we all
use lowering every day probably and one
of the most sort of commonly known one
is with linked queries so I'm hoping
that most people in the room who've used
a link query know you can basically
write there's two ways we can write with
query syntax or we can write with the
methods index and it's it's pretty
prevalent that these two things coexist
there's reasons for why you might want
one or the other even in Visual Studio
there's refactoring that offers you to
convert from one for the other Emeka
ghen the query syntax gets lowered by
the compiler into the methods in tax
rather than compiling both of these - IL
they simply convert from one form of
c-sharp to the other and compile that
and in fact these methods are extension
methods if you've ever written an
extension method you know that it's just
a fancy way of writing a static method
so you can go even further and say that
well you could lower but that method
form of a link query into normal static
method calls so all of this stuff is
happening all the time in c-sharp
something as simple as defining a
variable this has to be lowered right
there is no il concept for VAR there's
no even the dotnet concept of var var is
a c-sharp field so the c-sharp compiler
in order to produce a dotnet DLL has to
do something with it that dotnet
understands so the compiler essentially
rewrites your code or pretends that you
wrote string so we're all using this all
the time it's also used to optimize or
optimize but improve your code there's
minor little optimizations the compiler
makes so if you write this code and you
had two string literals this could be
compiled down to call the add operator
on a string passed in the left hand side
in the right hand side that'll combine
these strings at runtime but the
compiler is smart enough to know that it
can do the same job at compile time so
to save time if you write that code
you're essentially compiling that code
compiler just lunges them together and
so there's lots of these little
optimizations if we have three parts to
our string now if these were all string
constants the same thing holds true as
was on the previous slide but if these
are parameters or variables or fields or
anything else it can't the compiler
can't do that at compile time obviously
there has to be that at runtime so
logically with the plus operator you
would have to do this
operators in c-sharp have a left hand
side in the right hand side they only
have two parameters so you would have to
have a temporary variable and part 1 and
part 2 together then add part 3 to our
temporary variable the compiler does
this all the time to make allow you to
write you know easy code without
defining these temporary variables
yourself but of course if it did that
that temporary variable is now something
the garbage collector has to go and
clean up
all right that's an allocation that you
may be
intend so to improve this if you write
this top bit of code what the compiler
actually does is love as a two-string
concat witch pre-allocate s-- one string
copies the bits in and the way we go so
there's all these really small little
optimizations that you're getting the
benefit of all the time even something
as simple as this again that M is not a
dotnet thing that's the c-sharp thing so
that is calling a constructor of yeah
system decimal it's not very exciting
but that's what's happening so why do we
care
well there's kind of two reasons number
one is understanding about the
performance of your code that's the
reason that if you want to go home and
tell your boss on Monday that's the time
to stick with I write code like this all
the time because this is what my brain
says to do or possibly just my fingers
do it without my brain even catching up
concatenating strings let's just want to
do some people like string format some
people like this way I go this way and
in c-sharp six string interpolation the
way interpolate strings came out and
everyone in the code base I was working
on went and changed them all to this
which is cool this is very readable I
like the little coloring you get in
video studio with the count thing that's
cool but if you know what the compiler
does with your code when this came out
every time someone changed the top line
there to that second form
it's a readability improvement but I saw
a potential performance degradation
because string interpolation lowers to
string dot format and string dot format
is generally speaking slower than string
concatenation now it's slower because it
does more and it does good stuff it does
like culture sensitive things so in this
example with count here I'd actually
argue that top line is probably wrong
and it probably should have been string
format because if count was more than a
thousand you might want the little
thousand separator and of course whether
that's a comma like appear right 1 comma
0 0 0 in Europe it would be a dot string
dot format is aware of that
maybe I shouldn't mentioned Europe today
but never Munt so this is a potential
performance regression let's say right
this is probably unlikely to break your
app and make it crumble but you never
know it's something to be aware of now
the good thing is that since C sharp
sticks came out I think like maybe six
months afterwards there was a
contribution from the community that
improved string interpolation so it it
will also lower to string doc and cat if
it can so there's kind of less reasons
to worry now essentially well you kind
of don't have to worry cuz if it's going
to use the string format call if there's
an argument it always should have been
but so performance is kind of the not
really performance either just
understanding performance it's kind of
the main reason but the other reason
that I like to know is because I like to
know I'm interested in this sort of
thing and it's funny because I think
I've seen this quote at least three
times this week
because I think this is a very common
thing that all developers like to
understand how things work and so that's
why I like to know so back to our for
each loop though this is a for each loop
it's not very exciting for um in values
now the body of the loop there I've
colored in green because I want you to
ignore it it's like a comment right from
the compilers point of view we assume
that it doesn't know what's inside the
loop obviously it does because it has to
compile it but by extension note even if
it knew the console dot write lines here
it doesn't know what console dot write
line does so that kind of doesn't factor
it but needless to say that's the body
it's green so you can see where it goes
so what does the compiler do when we get
the for each loop so we can't talk about
for each without talking about fire
enumerable an ienumerable of T they're
relatively simple interfaces ienumerable
has one method which returns an
enumerator it's called get enumerator
and an enumerator has a current which is
the current thing we're pointing at it
has a move next which returns whether
the move worked not whether there is
more but whether we did move and it has
a reset method which no one has ever
called and then ienumerable of T and I
knew
of T is the same thing but we redefine a
couple of things in terms of T I am sure
this is one of these examples where if
generics existed from C sharp 1 this
would look a lot cleaner because this is
kind of you know but anyway but so for
each works on Eire numerals right
everyone knows that but it kind of
doesn't let's write a for each loop so I
will write this
no thank you right I'll write a Forex
loop now obviously this doesn't compile
but I'm going to have a thing that's
what I want and I'm going to create a
class called my femur so this doesn't
compile as you would expect and if we
hover over this you can't read it
because visual shooter doesn't zoom tool
tips but that says blah blah blah blah
blah getenumerator but it doesn't say
you don't implement ienumerable it just
says you don't have a getenumerator
method and in fact if we write one let's
call this one my enumerator I love that
it suggests the name it's so clever you
know what I don't even actually need to
do anything here if I do this and then
create that class so this still doesn't
compile but this error message you can't
see is slightly different this now says
you don't have a current and you don't
have a move next if I give this a
current yeah like an object it doesn't
really matter and we give it a move next
52 you can always be false and this now
compiles so there's no irony removals
and now I numerators is nothing for each
is pattern-based
which is the boring way of saying it's
duck types meaning if it looks like a
duck and sounds like a duck and walks
like a duck and it's probably a duck so
this is interesting thing number one
about Forex loops
yes my first time using virtual desktops
it's very exciting to worked so all this
stuff with ienumerable
see I didn't even need reset because no
one ever calls reset you actually don't
like we don't need that so the compiler
doesn't use it either so what does it
look like the first thing the compiler
has to do when we have a for each loop
is we have to introduce a scope so it's
very subtle but there are braces there
and that's simply because you know our m
in our loop we can't use that anywhere
else so we have to contain it easy
enough so we call get a numerator on our
values and we get it back there's no
castes there's no checking if it's
ienumerable etc all those things we just
call get any route you can kind of think
of this as as long as that line of code
compiles then everything is fine it's
not technically true because extension
methods don't work but that's a choice
that they made there's no great
technical reason why not on the numbers
you'll it'll break things but so we get
in the numerator and it's var because we
don't know what it is but we don't care
right as long as it has the right
methods we have a try finally because
error correction is good and then we
declare our loop variable and then while
we can move we move so that's about it
for eclipse lower to a while loop 15
minutes in good talk yet let's go bit
further
haven't used the current property yet so
we get our current value into our loop
variable and then we have our body which
we all gonna ignore right everyone happy
who's itching to raise their hand and
tell me thank you John
why are there two casts he says so this
is where for me it gets interesting
because knowing what a for each loop
does yeah it's it's a little bit
interesting I like knowing what the
compiler does so fine but when you get
up to something like why are there two
casts that's when I'm like okay I have
to find this out he sees me I just got
to bug me if I don't know so let us have
an aside this is a loop roll this is
pretend that two different developers
wrote this code in the boxier developer
a wrote an object array
put some mints into it and then call the
method that took an object array fine
developer B wrote a method that takes an
object array and pulled some ins out of
it so this looks fine and if you read
that in English it says for each int in
my array it kind of sounds like oh
that's going to go through my array find
the intz pulled them out and do
something with them
but if we look at the code on the left
which is what the compiler actually
outputs that's not true right that's not
what's happening there's no looking to
check if there's n so this just casts so
if you get the types in this wrong
you'll get an invalid cast exception
maybe some of you have seen this at
runtime it does happen and if you look
at the code on the right and you think I
mean why would you get an invalid cast
exception
there's no casts there well now you know
the compiler puts two in so there are
two casts going on here we have a cast
from int to object to go into the array
and we have a cast from object two in to
come out of the array but it kind of
doesn't explain it for me so I'm gonna
change the example a little bit but due
to space constraints it gets a bit
confusing so bear with me hopefully you
can follow a level if we change our
array e to a person array and we put
employees into it and then we instead of
pulling out in store persons we pull out
customers in the second bit this two
array is now become required so don't
forget this is developer a and B they've
never talked to each other they haven't
met right developer eyes job he's
putting employees into something that
wants people so he has to provide some
kind of way for that to work
it could be through inheritance that it
works it could be through an implicit
caste operator an explicit cast operator
doesn't matter somehow that translation
from employee to person has to work and
then develop a B they're writing
something that translates from person to
customer and so they have to write
something that makes that work but
they're each within their own domains
right so when this code runs current
will be an employee the first time it
gets cast it will be cast to a person
and that translation is supplied by
developer a and then the second time it
gets cast it will be cast to a customer
from a person and that translation is
supplied by developer B so that all
works if we only had one cast you will
be pulling out an employee
casting it to customer that could
potentially blow up but more importantly
from each developer's perspective that
is completely and utterly mysterious
right if you've wrote if you've written
a a method where you put employees into
something that takes people and it
throws up saying I expected customers
you have no idea what you have no idea
that he expected that and same thing if
you write a method that expects
customers and you'll get given employees
you have no idea that these two these
two developers might not even know the
other class exists so the two castes
allow this sort of pipeline through from
what we put in the array to what type of
things the array can store to what type
of things were pulling out of the forage
I find that interesting because I know
that I was never be smart enough to come
up with that if I was designing a
language but after the fact I could look
at it and go oh yeah I can't see other
words anyway and then we disposed things
and that's how it works
now the dispossess got a little bit of
poetic license as well because inside
the compiler it knows if you're I
disposable and it'll just leave out that
call if you're not but this is a
PowerPoint slide so you get that so
that's a Forex look it's cool if you go
home or go back to work on Monday and
you write a foreach loop and you compile
it and you look in aisle spied you look
at that DLL don't try and show off to
your workmates and say I know what this
is going to look like because it won't
look like this because this is a c-sharp
four for each lip a c-sharp five for
each that looks slightly different watch
the M in c-sharp five our int M
declaration moved inside the while loop
that's it that's all that happened this
solved so many Stack Overflow posts it
was ridiculous and again this is where
this stuff isn't really this is like
historical interesting now so what
happened he'd say sharp five that caused
this well that's actually a little bit
of a false question it's what happened
in c-sharp for that caused them for them
fix it as a sharp five
and well I won't spoil yet what happened
in c-sharp for is lick and lambdas right
and it exposed a way to say bug but
there was an assumption in people's code
and it was it was possible from back in
c-sharp to with anonymous delegates but
link you know made everyone start
writing more lambda expressions so it
just got a lot more noise but yeah
anyway I went I went spoiler but to talk
about with problem is we have talked
about closures which means we have to
talk about lambdas so a lambda in green
there or actually well in green is the
body of a lambda technically I guess the
lander includes the XP but anyway so
we're defining a lambda
it's an action it takes in one parameter
fine and we're going to call it
conceptually this lowers to this which
is your action is a method pointer we
call the action which ends up calling
the method great realistically this
isn't how the compiler works because
having this method here on your class
could potentially be a problem if again
because it doesn't know what's in the
body of the lambda right it doesn't know
what console the right loan what does it
could be something that that has to hold
this instance of C in memory forever so
if this class is a windows form with a
hundred controls and lots of event
handlers that uses up lots and lots
around whatever and defining one little
lambda is going to result in this being
held in memory for the entire life of
your application that could be a bad
thing so the compiler can't really prove
that this is going to happen or not
going to happen so all it does is it
tries to generate code that will avoid
it as much as a can which just means in
practice it generates a little class to
hold your method so that even if
something goes wrong in this class this
instance is held in memory at least it
knows it's generated the smallest
classic can there is one more step to
this which I'm not going to cover
because doesn't apply as soon as you
close over things which is what we're
talking about but if you're interested
you can go and find out about that later
but so here's essentially how a lambda
expression is lowered we have a helper
class that gets created we point to the
method on that helper class great so
what happens if we close over something
so closing over something means if we
modify our lambda to refer to something
from outside of it so just to recap this
is our lambda this is what it looks like
when it's lowered so if I add in a Y
here so we're now running out X plus y
we've defined Y locally so we're closing
over Y right the lambda is using
something from outside itself a code on
the right obviously this now doesn't
compile anymore because where does y I
come from so what happens is any local
variable that you're closing over gets
hoisted up to be a field on the helper
class so now this helper class now
compiles again we have a why every
reference to the local in your method
gets replaced with a reference to that
field so we create a class we set
something like a field call a method
right this is reasonably straightforward
if we change the value of Y to fish then
all we do is set that field to fish so
from this example it's relatively clear
hopefully that this is going to print
out hello fish right we're closing over
Y naught the value of Y but the variable
itself so we're always getting the
latest version of it when you write out
code like this that's its you know it's
reasonably expected once you bring loops
into the equation though things just get
a bit more hidden and it sort of
revealed some problems do let me know if
this is like - whatever this talks kind
of a bit of a roller coaster or if like
gets really complex or whatever and then
falls off a cliff at the end if you
should start to feel ill I won't be
offended if you leave put a green card
in so I know you were sick so let's go
back to our loop and we've got to change
our loop now to have lambdas in it so
instead of actually writing out what we
want to do we're gonna assemble a list
of things which I would probably call
tasks but that keyword is taken so our
loop now is just going to add things to
a list but it adds
and it's capturing our M so in c-sharp
for this is what that code looked like
we create an instance of our helper
because that's how we declare our M
right our M is now a field so how do you
yeah declare a field well you don't
really but you know you create an object
just to hold it and so then inside our
loop we're constantly setting that field
and then we're adding our lambdas in our
actions so later on when this gets when
these actions get called that's going to
print out the last value that M had
right the most recent value because it's
not closing over the value so in c-sharp
5 that moves inside the loop every item
in our list of things now gets its own
helper class or its own instance any way
and everything's works so the way this
manifested in c-sharp 4 was everybody
went gung ho with link they said yes
give me a list of all my customers and
then they loop through the customer and
they say give me a list of all their
orders and then every customer had the
lot had the orders from the last
customer in the list and it got to be
that I remember sitting that at so at
where I was working the time we had this
customer RM and we had a linked thing
and we succumb to this that fixed it and
then we were like looking on Stack
Overflow and you could just start
reading the first two sentences you go
oh yeah I know the answer this one
that's this problem and it you know
generated enough noise that they fixed
it this this is a breaking change in the
compiler which doesn't happen much
probably didn't break anyone maybe but
anyway before we finish on closures
though just to complete the story if we
close over something from outside the
method our lambda is in theme is get a
bit more tricky so we can't just hoist Z
up here to be a field on our class
because Zed is now living you know in
our outer scope it could be set by
another method on this class it could be
a public thing that gets set by who
knows what it could be a property or a
method that you know does some work so
this now has to capture the entire class
so it's actually capturing the this if
you think about it if this and said this
dot Z and of makes a bit more sense
right there's like an implementation
detail of what we're pulling off the
class it
has to close over the whole class so the
reason I mentioned this is back to
knowing about performance
characteristics earlier I said to avoid
potential memory problems it defines the
smallest class it can so it doesn't hold
your class in memory but if you do this
you're now forcing the compiler to
basically do the thing that it tried to
avoid doing so good to know
all right last thing on Forex loops is
yield coz yields are fun because yields
when you look at them they look like
magic and then when you peel the curtain
back they really don't anymore it's
kinda disappointing because you never
get that moment back but this is an
iterative method or get into the
iterative method so if you haven't used
one what will happen in c-sharp
conceptually is we call get ian's we get
back a 1 we do some work in this case
consult at write line and then somehow
we call gideon's again but we skip over
the 1 and somehow get to line 2 of that
method and run that code which seems
really weird so how does it work here is
our while loop I've simplified it down
just using the using statement and
here's our each array 2 method
so there's another helper get Ian's
helper in fact well I'll show you later
so yeah so we have another helper class
much like with our lambdas and we're
passing in minus 2 okay
the interesting thing here to note and
this is true of all for each loops get
int is only called once all right we
call get into immediately called getting
ready it's the enumerator that's
important numerator that we're going to
deal with get into itself is only called
once so I don't know maybe that's a clue
if you're really smart
not only anyway let's look at our helper
I'll help it implement every interface
because it should I guess to be fairer
and it has a few fields it has a state
field which kind of spoils the fun gives
the game I as a current because it's an
enumerator it has a value has an initial
thread ID because we're going to do some
threading although not much it's ok it
has to implement some things from the
interface that's fine
it has a constructor which gets the
initial state which was minus two very
good and it captures the current thread
has a disposed method which doesn't do
anything and it has a reset method which
doesn't do anything because nobody ever
calls reset and then it hasn't
getenumerator method which starts to get
a bit oh I'm sorry I'm just like
throwing all this code at you but at
least there's not many generics so get a
numerator let's just talk through it so
if our state is minus two which it is
and we're still on the same thread set
state to zero and return ourselves
otherwise if any of those conditions are
met create a new instance of ourselves
or year of this type and return that so
this is another one of those little
optimizations where in the best case the
compiler is trying to write code that
will do the best thing so if you have an
iterative method and you call it and
loop through it on the same thread and
only ever do it once or only ever yeah
then you'll just use one instance of
this helper but if that's not true in
order to not mix up you know your each
raises arm I was pointing at three now
at seven we create multiple instances so
again performance it's good to know as
soon as you need to write a method you
could get lots of instances of these
helpers created one per thread or just
one per time it's used in your method
and then we have our move next method
and if you didn't work it out from the
state field this is the state machine so
the way you split up that method to do
line one then line to then line three is
you rewrite it into a switch statement
that has case in this case and in this
case so move next is the method that's
called lots and lots of times right
that's the one that we look through so
every time move next is called
another chunk of our method is executed
and we set state to point to the next
one it's kind of like disappointingly
simple because yield looks so magical
and obviously this gets a bit Messier
when there's other code in the mix but
essentially all of the other code goes
in the middle here the state variable
the state field it transitions a lot so
minus one
that it's fetching the next value which
in this case is just a one and then the
state represents the thing and then
there's other there's minus three states
you'll see there's all sorts of things
but so this is essentially it's just a
signature what other state machines are
in c-sharp that have moved next methods
async/await
so once you know how your works cuz you
can write a very simple example with
yields you might feel brave enough to
then go on to async/await but you have
to be very brave because it's very messy
but essentially this is very similar to
yield right we're going to run some code
now we're going to wait for something to
happen in the yield case we knew what it
was we were going to go back here and do
some whatever it's in we don't really
know what's going to happen in this but
essentially do some code something we
stopped executing this method and then
we want to come back in and if you've
ever seen an exception from an async
method the word move next appears a lot
and now you know why I'm kind of
guessing that at some point someone just
copied the code from you to writer and
they just started working hell I woulda
done it
and so our move next method and I'm not
showing I think awake because that's
like could be an entire talk but I'll
move next method is not dissimilar we
have a state we come in we execute our
first bit of our code then well we're
gonna await a task delay so we get in a
waiter again as an optimization it
checks have we already finished on a
task dr. lay probably not but you know
you never know sometimes tasks can
finish quickly and before anything
happens but if we haven't finished we
said our state variable ready for the
next one we go off and do whatever magic
it happens to stop this and wait here
and hook up callbacks but then
essentially at some point we'll come
back in to move next our states now zero
we execute our second chunk of code we
do they get a waiter now this is the
state bid is is interesting because if
you've ever if you ever have to debug an
async method like with tools like windbg
or visually I can show you this stuff
the state field is where you are up to
in this method countered by the number
of await keywords starting from the top
of your method going to the bottom and
so it can actually really help you like
if this
an exception from you know after right
line three your exceptions not coming
from my async method it's gonna come
from move next it's gonna come from this
whole other class but so if you can find
out the state field and what value is
you just go and look at all right we're
up to there so let's bring it all
together hmm kind of I cheated a bit
this some more in this if you weren't
convinced yet why this is interesting to
know this is some completely arbitrary
and silly code but it doesn't do much
it's not very exciting it's got a couple
of loops it's about ten lines code if
you looked at this code and your or your
perhaps your manager looked at this code
and said this is too slow or this uses
too much memory or whatever improve the
performance of this code at first glance
this code has one loop two loops it's
kind of it it hasn't auto by like you
could find a faster sort algorithm maybe
it's kind of hiding all of its
complexity but if we know what the
compiler does well okay this loop that's
just gonna be a while loop that's fairly
safe fairly standard we have an iterator
method though so that's going to get a
helper class created we're gonna have an
instance of that we might have one
instance per thread if this is some high
blowed threaded console that right line
app that could be a problem inside that
helper well we're gonna have a state
machine that returns a one that's easy
but it also has a yield return inside
another loop which I didn't cover but
essentially that means that inside that
that helper class that is an enumerator
it stores another enumerator which is
the one for the inner loop more
importantly it's that helper class uses
this dot mean so it's gonna keep a
reference to that whole class that this
is all sitting in it also uses max which
is gonna get host to a field that's fine
no it's not sorry it's not now it is
because it has a lambda right so we're
going to get a helper class for our
lambda that's going to live on our
helper class for our iterator they're
both going to capture the class that the
one of those things could exist per
thread and that's the one that has the
other right so you can sort of start to
see that all this complexity whatever
can creep into your code now that's not
to say you shouldn't use these features
because they're fantastic right these
are this is the reason to write C sharp
and not just write IL and goto
statements is because it has these
high-level functions but if you're aware
of what's going on when there comes to
be a problem hopefully you can make some
more interesting choices so you've done
it thank you well done you survived all
the code I was going to show you or at
least the PowerPoint code but where to
next because hopefully maybe you're
interested in this stuff now or were
before and that's why you came here
probably so there's a few few
recommended things I would say if you're
brave the Roseland compiler is awesome
and actually you don't even have to be
that brave let me zoom across here so
this is Roselyn this is the c-sharp
compiler and if we look in the Microsoft
code analysis c-sharp there's a folder
here called lowering and it's not very
exciting it has about eight files in it
and it has a folder for hey iterators we
talked at them and lambdas we talked
about them these are all called
rewriters because what happens is right
none of this stuff actually rewrites
your c-sharp that was a complete lie but
the compiler passes your c-sharp into a
syntax tree and the rewriters rewrite
the nodes of that tree so some of them
are reasonably complex like async inner
areas and lambda they do a bunch of work
so they've got their own folders with
classes and things but there's this
folder here called local rewriter and it
has lots and lots and lots of files
because lowering is used in lots and
lots places my favorite well I'm not my
favorite but one of my favorites is if
the if rewriter I like because I always
think of if statements as being
extremely simple and I said that il
could do branching which is basically an
if statement so why does it need to be
rewritten
so the cool thing about Rosslyn is the
comments in this bit are awesome they
pretty much for every one of these there
is a comment that says this code becomes
and it shows you what the app that's
going to
and it shows you in this pseudo not
really IL but also not really see sharp
thing but you can see so if condition
run some code well as I said if the very
start il doesn't have blocks we can't
say run this bit of code so what we have
to do is flip the condition and say if
we're not running skip that bit of code
right so back to branching if we look at
for each there's actually four different
lowerings in here and this or this file
also got slightly more complicated since
I did the slides because now it's a
sinking numerable as well but this is
not a big not a big difference there but
so you can see this is essentially what
I had on the slides right here's our two
casts V and T because I don't know they
always use single letters I never know
what they mean but if we scroll down
like even the bits of it this is the bit
responsible for two lines like as you
read this you kind of can get used to it
eventually it's a bit weird where are we
to introduce you to do I'm just going to
scape shop nope we're still in the first
one to do nope uh yeah so this is a
special case for for each which for any
collection that has indexing so you know
how I said for each lowest two while
what turns out I'm just full of lies it
also lowers to four if we have indexing
right so there's four different special
well there's one general case I guess in
40 min special cases this uses iron your
bubble even less there's one for I think
it's arrays and strings I can't remember
no no lower for each Oh Celia single
dead dimensional array and there's one
more did you do multiracial way
otherwise it strings anyway so yeah
Rozlyn is you know the source of truth
for this stuff but it can be hard to
read especially well here this
expression is this which is like you
know six characters out to what eight
lines and some of the some of the rear
and not written so verbose Lee is this
and they're just like he is a new node
look and it's all backwards because you
know you have to pass in the things
inside you so it's all your gonna read
it backwards so it's be weird so Roslyn
can be confronting your favorite
decompiler is an option and well that's
true
Sharpe lab is my favorite decompiler
although it's not technically a
decompiler so sharp lab if you haven't
used it and if my oh come on this could
mean the Wi-Fi is not working II you
worked so this is sharp lab sharp lab I
oh it's a lovely open source free thing
written by a lovely man in New Zealand
and what it does is you type in code on
the left which that's the example from
my slide and it will compile your code
and by default it uses the latest
c-sharp compiler but you can select
whichever compiler you want including
these c-sharp next things these are
actual feature branches from the Rozlyn
github repository so you can test out
function pointers to your heart's
content
I don't even know if they'll ever make
it in c-sharp but you can still compile
them but then what it does well in in
one of its modes because it has a bunch
of different modes here as well but what
it does is so it's compiled this code in
c-sharp eight and then what it does is
it says to il spy which is what it uses
to decompile it says hey can you
decompile this code please I wrote it in
c-sharp one so all of the features that
have been added to c-sharp 8ielts five
doesn't get to use and then it also
turns off a bunch of other things so
that I ask why doesn't use any of them
so this is you know it's kind of as
close to raw representation as you can
get it's as John says you shouldn't
trust it it's not real but then none of
this is real because lowering doesn't
actually happen to c-sharp it happens to
bound loads on a tree but we don't read
bound nodes rather actually I think that
is one of the options here yes index but
so this is this is where our you know
eight line for each loop that doesn't do
much turns out to actually do quite a
lot of things do to do to do look see I
told you no one ever calls reset
but yeah so he's out getting a numerator
he's out state machine he is where we're
at Co I said there was another
enumerator inside the state machine
that's s2 for those playing at home
here's our actual code he is out
rewritten getting into method which
creates a helper so sharp lab is awesome
for looking at this sort of thing and it
shows you everything I think of I gotta
go back a bit more yeah
the I think one just to if I don't
really wanted me to show I think well
I'm not going to because it's horrible
oh that's a good idea
so what yeah oh right sorry yes yes so
the eight but the I think the async case
is particularly I want so confusing but
it's not how to read because if you look
so we have our statements here we have
go twos inside all these cases but then
they all flow through to this one which
then jumps around within itself so yeah
but basically it's we come in we do some
work we're going to await but if we've
already completed then we want to just
continue rather than wait to be called
back again there's kind of why jumps
around but it this gets you know messy
it doesn't help that all these things
have silly names but you're kind of
gonna extract them out let me talk the
good names in BS so sharp web is is like
I love sharp lab it can also run your
code it can show I li can do a bunch of
things uh wrong way I told you ahead and
use this before yeah so shop lub I think
that yes that's all yes there you go
thank you
I've ruined it for myself the effort
what I was going to say was the yeah the
performance thing is the reason to
understand this and hopefully maybe some
of you are just interested but I find
myself forever just you know if I'm
writing some code don't know what it is
but there's just like at least once a
week I will be curious about ah is this
the best way to do this or should I do
something else and I'll go to sharp lab
and I'll find out and it goes along with
you know reading the code of the dotnet
framework since we now can do that there
and see yo is this method implemented
better or whatever and it just helps you
hopefully prevent problems would also
understand them and then yeah if anyone
has any questions feel free or I will
hang around cool